Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
Today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians!
It's been a while!
You miss us?
Thank you for joining us for our 66th episode today!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
Sleep, sleep, sleep.
Homework.
Well, we're gonna do our best all together today!
Ruffians!
Maybe it's your first time, maybe it's not your first time, but just so you know,
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.k.a.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw!
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, are you feeling refreshed?
Refreshed?
Good to go!
Maybe not, it's Wednesday.
Wednesday's not really a refreshing day.
But, maybe you went somewhere fun recently?
I don't know.
I think there's been another Pero Sighting.
And this time, Pero was spotted.
Cafe?
Oh, this looks like a super cute cafe!
A super cute cafe!
Oh, they have those croissant cubes too, huh?
I like croissant cubes.
Croissant cubes!
It's pretty fun!
It's sort of fancy.
But, uh, there's one there that looks like it doesn't really belong, huh?
Is that... Pero?
Pero-san?
I'll have a petal of sun, please!
One petal of sun, please!
You know, it's not like I want one.
I just want to see it.
Why not just, you know, get a petal of sun?
And then you can give it to some seagulls or something.
You can watch them rip it apart!
That sounds good, yeah!
It could be, you know, some morning entertainment.
Well, what is Pero trying to do here though, huh?
Is he trying to get eaten?
Well, maybe not the seagulls, but maybe his plan is to get taken home with a cute girl who likes going around and trying new cafes.
I don't know.
Maybe that's kind of weird.
Yeah, I don't know if he has white chocolate inside.
But kind of a nice hope.
But I think at the very least there's...
BAU BAU!
You might get food poisoning.
You like your petal-less on boneless?
You have to make sure that the tag there, it says boneless.
Boneless petal-less.
You have to pay attention to the line print.
Got it.
You have the croissants with the bones and then the boneless croissants.
It's the two types of croissants, okay?
Bones, boneless.
Got it.
Extra crunch, extra crunch.
The crunch sound is your teeth.
Well, Ruffians, there's been a lot of exciting things happening here with FUWAMOCO.
But more happiness!
White Lava's most recent song cover has reached 200,000 views!
Thank you, Ruffians!
You know, maybe the winter is coming to an end where you are, but we really love it if you could continue to listen to it all year round, okay?
You know, it's a really emotional song and we put all of ourselves into it.
Yeah, you know, but we're really just so happy that you enjoy it this much, despite it being an older song, a bit of an older song, and maybe not so well known outside of Japan.
Thank you so much, ruffians!
We'll continue to work hard to put out new music and cover songs, okay?
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
My love is red hot!
I'm your favorite chihuahua!
Mama puppy likes it a lot, too.
BAU BAU!
Mama puppy was comparing it.
She's silly.
We talked on the phone and then she had to phone us back right after to ask about it.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
Something cool just happened just an hour ago!
Do you know what it was?
Do you?
Oh, I see one thing.
Not that one.
Ruffians!
Ai-senpai and Holomith just dropped a new original song all together called Reunion!
BAU BAU!
Did you check it out?
It's on the official hololive English channel.
What you did for the premiere?
What you think?
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm FUWAMOCO!
They're really cute and touching.
In English, though, you know I can touch you straight in the heart!
And you know, we're just so happy to see all our senpai happy together.
But... You saw us complain about the YouTube premiere volume?
No, you didn't!
My ears were... destroyed.
No, not at all!
But it was okay because your ears, your hearing was reunited when you hear her reunion, right?
Right!
It's the reason why I choose the premiere music I do.
But Ruffians, if you weren't able to check it out, please go and do so right after this.
Like Moco-chan said, after this.
After, okay?
It'll warm up your heart for sure.
BAU BAU!
And more exciting things!
I saw a lot of ruffians talk about this because this is kind of the talk of the hour.
The hour?
The hour talk of the day.
Talk of the week.
Talk of the month.
Big talk.
And more amazing news!
Marine-senchou-senpai just reached 3 million subscribers on YouTube!
BAU BAU BAU!
That's so amazing!
That is crazy.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my goodness.
I was so happy for her.
Mari-senchou-senpai!
Congratulations on 3 million subscribers!
Congratulations!
BAU BAU!
3 million is a rare number.
3 million... That's amazing.
You know, seeing all the things that Marine-sensho-senpai does really, really inspires us.
You know, we hope that we can be just a little, little bit like her one day and release a lot of really amazing creative works and music.
Actually, sometimes,
FUWAMOCO.
We have a little bit of a tendency to get a bit gloomy.
I'm wondering, you know, if we can ever be anywhere near how amazing My Essential Senpai is.
Yeah, but, you know, we just remind ourselves that, you know, we are FUWAMOCO.
And it hasn't been a year since we debuted.
So, you know, we're just being some baby steps, right?
Baby steps.
BAU BAU!
Well, ruffians, I think... I think...
We might have gotten a bit of a scoop from you!
A scoop?
We got a scoop from a ruffian this one!
Thank you!
Thank you so much for the impeccable journalism!
Doi doi doi!
I scooped it!
Biboo.
Biboo was spreading the curse so well.
Well, during the whole cup.
You know, there is some time where we could actually try to appeal ourselves to everybody watching the stream, right?
Yeah.
Biboo did a good job, you know?
She decided to do what she does best and be silly!
And that was while dancing to the No Rizzler song.
Yeah.
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
She definitely stood out there, but it also seems like there might be some JPNki that are a little bit confused about the song.
You know, it's not necessarily a song filled with love for Abyss, although, you know, we feel like it.
I feel like that.
It makes me feel warm and fluffy.
Yeah.
It's actually supposed to be kind of an annoying song.
Is that because it's too catchy?
It's very catchy, right?
You know the lyrics are strange, but I think it means well.
I think so too.
Ruffians, are you ever like us where sometimes you like wake up in the middle of the night and be like BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
That part, you know.
That part.
I'm sorry, ruffians.
Did we hurt you just now?
It'll be okay soon.
It means we're okay.
You can't be mad if it means we're okay.
Yeah, but Biboo definitely did a good job standing out.
You made us proud, Biboo!
We were so proud!
An amazing job in the Chiyo Club, too.
BAU BAU!
Amazing.
It's emotional, ruffians.
If you don't feel emotional, I think something's wrong with you, okay?
BAU BAU!
Well, ruffians...
You know how just recently we did a viral response on Twitter, right?
We responded to some of your tweets.
Thank you for so many tweets!
We had so much fun, but doing it, we got a question asking Moco-chan if she felt that
I, Fuwawa, me, Fuwawa, if I'm a skeevy dog, a skeevy dog, and me, Fuwawa, I responded back saying that, well, maybe it's Koyori-senpai's fault, you know it.
Right?
Right, ruffians?
A scaby dog.
That's what Koyori-senpai said.
But you know, Koyori-senpai, as you can see, she caught wind of it.
Yeah, who told on us, ruffians?
Right, who told on us?
So she asked Moco-chan directly if she thought that.
I don't know if I was a skeevy dog.
Moco-chan, you said that we're both the same.
We're not that skeevy.
You know, we're always together.
So, I don't know why, ruffians, why do you think we're so different?
I don't know why you think this.
We're always together.
We're not that different.
But you know, Koyori-senpai, she doesn't really seem to believe this though, huh?
No.
What do you think, ruffians?
We aren't skeevier than Koyori-senpai, right?
We are pretty different, right?
We're twins, but we have different points.
We're not that different.
We have the same likes, the same skills.
We aren't different.
Thank you, that's true.
We're twins, okay?
Pink.
Blue.
Yes.
I don't know what Koyori-senpai's thinking, but we hope that we can play lots and learn lots from Koyori-senpai in the near future!
It was really fun at the club.
We're so lucky to be surrounded by
So many amazing senpai that we can learn from.
We feel like that every single day.
I feel funny being like, I love senpai!
But it's true.
It's hard not to love all your senpai when they're all so talented and so nice.
Amazing and nice.
Sorry.
BAU BAU!
Okay, so the conclusion is, we're not
We're not skeevy dogs, ruffians!
Koeri-senpai is a skeevy dog?
Is Koeri-senpai a skeevy dog?
She's a skeevy dog.
There's the answer.
BAU BAU!
Well, it's the middle of the week somehow.
Ruffians is this week on as fast as it has been.
You as it has us.
Hopefully it has, but it is not!
Moco-chan, you have some words, right?
Ruffians!
It's that time again!
It's time that you're gonna listen up, because this here is a Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear it straight from me, Mococo!
Somehow, we're already into the thick of it!
The thick of 2024!
You know, it can be pretty exciting.
A new year, a bunch of plans!
But, sometimes, it can be a bit overwhelming too.
Sometimes it can feel like it's hard to see which way you need to go, right?
But you know, when you feel a bit overwhelmed and aren't sure what to do with your feelings, sometimes the best thing you can do is just take a step back for a bit.
Maybe go on a bit of a walk!
Try something new!
That way, maybe you can figure out why you feel that way and can come back feeling refreshed and ready to go!
Sometimes, you know,
Giving yourself a push towards your goal is necessary, but pushing yourself hard to do something that you don't want to do isn't always the right answer.
You have to think of the importance of the journey, not just the destination, okay?
And you know, I hope that if you ever feel a bit overwhelmed, that you feel comfortable coming back here to us for headbutts.
And that you know, when we feel a bit overwhelmed,
Remember when you're feeling a bit overwhelmed.
We're always waiting here, okay?
We'll be here for you.
BAU BAU!
Do we have a Doggie of the Day today?
Well, today's Doggie of the Day is... It's Stella!
BAU BAU!
She's ready for this!
You know, it looks like a really good orange.
I haven't had any oranges for a while.
Mochi, if you put kagami mochi in my head... It'd probably fall and then I'd eat it.
BAU BAU!
How do you think Stella BAU BAUs?
You know, with the... With the orange on the hat there.
BAU BAU.
A bit disappointed.
Gaman shiteru you de.
BAU BAU.
Holding back.
Trying to stay up a little bit.
BAU BAU.
BAU BAU in the star!
She's such a good girl.
And beautiful too!
I think
She had a very wonderful end of the year and start of the year together with you as well.
And you know, even though she can't eat the orange right now, I think she knows she'll get an orange eventually.
Eventually.
She better.
But after, maybe a month from now, there'll be a lot of yummies waiting for her.
Ruffians!
You've been out going for walks, right?
It is a threat.
Go on a walk.
Let's see what walks you've been on.
Today's walk is... De-den!
It looks like it was the perfect weather for a nice walk in the countryside, huh?
It looks like a movie.
It's kind of glossy.
But we're so glad that you were able to get out and decompress from the busyness of everything.
Actually, it sort of reminds me of a princess movie.
A princess movie!
You know what?
It looks like a princess movie.
Nice lily pads?
Yeah, cause there's lily pads in princess movies, huh?
This ruffian leper walked right into a princess movie, huh?
Exactly!
You didn't know it, but you're the princess.
Hopefully he can go on more good walks soon.
BAU BAU!
No, but you're the princess.
You're the princess!
Congratulations!
And for our question of the day... We have de-den!
Hello, FUWAMOCO!
Hello!
We know every hololive member gets to ask for a wish.
Within reason, when they reach 1 million subscribers, have you given any thought about what yours might be?
Well...
I have one million wishes.
We've actually thought about it a little bit.
But you know, we still have a ways to go.
But we're going to work hard so that maybe it can be sooner than later.
But I think that we would both like to wish for something that would be hard to make come true normally.
Something maybe that requires a lot of talented individuals to make.
But you know, we're not sure what the rules are, you know?
Surely we can't just wish for anything.
Right.
Could you wish for two wishes?
See, I don't think so.
I don't think so.
Yeah, but you know, we have some good ideas, you know.
And based on what we're allowed to do, let's use what we think is best.
Right.
Wish for more wishes!
That would be cool if we get two wishes, but I don't think that's very fair to the other members, right?
Right.
So... Ask for 1.5 wishes?
We'll just have to ask for very very good wishes.
Wrestling stream!
Wrestling stream.
Would you want that for our 1 million views?
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Would you be happy?
Would you think?
Okay.
FUWAMOCO, I'm good with that.
They made a good decision.
Yes!
We'll think about it.
We'll have to think about it.
One million wishes.
We're excited for that wish to come true one day.
More than anything, we're just looking forward to the journey together with you all.
Exactly.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, FUWAMOCO fans, for all your submissions for making FUWAMOCO Morning what it is.
We're always looking forward to more Doggie of the Day, seeing what walks you're going on, and which movie you're gonna walk into next, huh?
Yeah, and your questions, and also Pero Sightings too.
Always waiting, okay?
And!
For your journalism with the FUWAMOCO scoop too, put on a journalism hat!
Thank you so much for watching!
BAU BAU!
It's going to be really, really soon.
We're gonna have to eat a lot of sushi, so make sure, Moco-chan, that your tummy is empty, okay?
Empty tummy.
Best way to return!
We're gonna have a lot of fun, so we hope you'll be there, maybe!
Ruffians, you can have sushi too with us!
BAU BAU!
And if we take a little peek at our schedule here, well, we have some lethal company collabs, but between that, we have a rock n' roll party!
Rock n' roll party!
Are you excited, ruffians?
The first rock n' roll party of the year!
Right!
After our countdown one, that kind of is right in between.
I'd say it's more 2023 than anything.
Yeah, yeah.
Excited!
Can we not tell them now?
No, let's tell them Friday is a bit late.
No, I can tell them Friday is a bit late.
Friday?
You okay with Friday, Ruffians?
You okay with Friday?
FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
Nemurenai yoru ni wa.
No, that's not the thing!
But this time we're going to be less silly.
So we hope that you're ready to hear some great thoughts about BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
We're looking forward to spending some more fun times together, ruffians!
Thank you!
Thank you for waking up early and joining us for another FUWAMOCO Morning today!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our extra special ruffians!
Night Owl!
BAU BAU!
Doya Doya!
Mouse.
BAU BAU!
Sarukakos.
Gokuma.
BAU BAU!
Kakamuka.
I got a banana.
BAU BAU!
Bookworm.
Ponpon.
BAU BAU!
Serayu.
Sake!
BAU BAU!
Yum!
Potion!
BAU BAU!
And to every other ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!